well in the u.s as
senate democrats gear up for donald
trump's second impeachment trial in a
week's time
the former president has until today
tuesday to formally respond to the
charge against him
he's accused of inciting the deadly
insurrection at the capitol on
january 6th meanwhile the investigation
into the riot itself
continues scores of people have already
been arrested
in what's amounting to a probe of
unparalleled scope
dw correspondent stephan simons reports
from washington
[Applause]
fierce and diehard supporters of donald
trump scaling the walls of the u.s
capitol
these images showing what is now called
an attack on democracy
an insurrection and failed coup attempt
in which five people died
still causes disbelief and concern shock
and anxiety for millions of americans
today
however just hours after the storming of
capitol hill on january 6
federal authorities started multiple
investigations
in how exactly this happened and who is
responsible for it all
almost four weeks after the attack on
capitol hill this fence and the barbed
wire are pretty much the only visual
signs and reminders
of what had happened on january 6 here
but behind the curtains and behind the
doors
the investigation into what happened and
who is responsible for this
is in full gear hundreds of fbi agents
at headquarters in washington and from
dozens of field offices all across the
u.s are following
thousands of leads federal agents are
sifting through an
unprecedented amount of evidence
including at least 200 000 digital
tip-offs
from various social media platforms
at least 300 people are under active
investigation
and at least 150 have been arrested so
far
officials say this was just the first
phase of what they say
is an investigation of unprecedented
scope the investigation will
shift a little bit from low-hanging
fruit of people
let's say who filmed themself attacking
and getting into
the capital committing one crime or
another it will shift
now into a more complex and
complicated way why is that because now
the fbi
will look into conspiracy in
organization
in organized crime how much
was organized of this attack what was
the
level of sophistication in preparing for
the attack and who was involved
federal authorities say they are in for
the long haul when it comes to their
investigations and answering these and
other questions
back on capitol hill the temporary fence
surrounding much of it
will perhaps also remain for longer than
originally planned
the interim chief of the capitol police
wants it to become
a permanent fixture
you